what's up guys welcome back to the couch
joined by small today if you have
noticed it's a bit darker it's darker
because I'm forcing myself to play that
he Resident Evil yeah you love it if
anybody saw that I was like out last
video I did I hate horror games I get
spooked so easily but to move
cherry-picked a piece of yeah this is
this is a bit of Resident Evil which
won't be too spoilery if you're looking
to go into this completely fresh then it
might be something that you want to
avoid until after but this is an area of
the game has been shown in trailers has
been shown in extended gameplay sessions
and it's a it's one that I really like
because it perfectly encapsulates what
it's great about the new Resident Evil
game it's it's everything from like the
pacing of this area to kind of what
you're up against to sound design to
some of the little trickery uses to kind
of manipulate your emotional state and
your mental state it's in its finest
form here and there's a little bit of
narrative exposition and if we get to it
there should be a decent set-piece
moment that will end on whether you get
through it or not is a different manner
I barely got to the point of getting to
this part yes so you play through the
bit up until this point which we didn't
want to show because it is quite spoiler
thick and it's something that you don't
want to experience on your own for the
first time it's a good sell piece but
well this this is where it gets real I
think I'll ever be ready so whatever
just get over who are you people
where's Mia
eat it it's good sumbitch hit it boys
got to eat he got the feast
oh my days
[Music]
he doesn't seem disturbed about having
his arm cough
it's meet level
it was all broad if they've left me with
oh dear so most of the game takes place
on the Baker estate which is very much
inspired by Texas Chainsaw Massacre so I
did a two-part documentary called
reviving Resident Evil which you can
watch now available on the website along
with like various articles interviews
and that kind of stuff to go and said
good to coincide with it and one of the
developers spoke of his love for stuff
like Stephen King and Texas Chainsaw
Massacre specifically and the
inspirations that that has for those
have had on this game are obvious it's
not like leaning on it to a fault I feel
like it takes a lot of the mood and not
the aesthetic of it and it does its own
thing with it but you will get that kind
of that scene for example if you watch
our documentary there's a bit where Adam
the editor for it basically cut together
that scene along with the dinner scene
from Texas Chainsaw Massacre I really so
it's and they basically blend in
perfectly to each other it's really
really cleverly done on Adams part and
you get see the inspiration behind it
and also you know other kind of they
talk about in our interview the sense of
isolation you feel in this kind of area
which is why they've chosen the
Louisiana bayou
as their setting you it's a large
expanse of land but you also kind of
stuck this isolate you know is you know
something cool there if you move around
she's following me yeah she's just
watching you oh yeah so you're isolated
so a lot of the game takes place on the
Baker estate you're always on the Baker
estate but the Baker estate is quite
large and that kind of for people who
might have been worried that this lower
house doesn't compare to something like
the Spencer mansion in the first game or
the reckon C Police Department
it's it's definitely got an expansive
game Ward V to explore I guess a nascar
dance the barrage you just need to get
out here don't like anything about this
the last rosy game I played was resi 5
and that was like a shooter yep this is
for those who have been what kind of
industrial tape can't be removed by hand
because that have been looking for a
return to survival horror this is this
is it I feel like and by now our review
should be up as well so you can see what
we thought about that game in the game
international you oh you don't want to
stay away from Jack Baker move quickly
with me you can do a quick spin using
pressing down encircle keep an eye on
him don't run too far away you need to
you need to see where he's going
did you can come this way not a no easy
car you meant to me you meant to be
helping me here
five words if he catches me why just
dead
maybe so what what am I supposed to be
doing here finding a way out but how do
I do that you do get past Jack get past
him play this game twice I've never had
him come this far out genuinely have not
seen him come this far out I've never
backed up from that point I have no idea
where he is now he'll that's the beauty
of this game my god okay remember that
hatch in that room yeah you need to get
there now you basically need to go to
where he is he's walking he's getting a
bit oh my god you're in trouble if he
comes back around this way really does
he come in says the window box I've
never seen him walked out far out so he
probably will come back this way I mean
you're not fully hidden in there
maybe you're right he's getting close
his voice again another he's I think
it's in the adjacent room there right or
maybe maybe have a little peek if you if
you just shuffle up yeah if you're close
to a wall and you just inch out you'll
see who blurs a bit
yeah it's blurring the stuff in put in
the distance that means that yeah you're
kind of basically hidden if he's in the
adjacent room you need to get into that
room yeah oh wait the door opened but
still I heard a door open that means
he's coming he's heard you've done it's
not running oh I'm so slow though oh
just frozen yeah just run up behind him
see if he'll run honey he's getting to
that room with the latch need to get in
there Oh Oh God yeah that's my leg fully
off
he'll get into let's you can get into
the whole series giving you think give a
finger thing from maybe I'll let you
take it you can use it to fix your leg
cut it back on its special o you
together quick oh my god
you sprint out spin out maybe not
and gets that little dog oh oh my days I
said go ahead I sent you back that way
so was was I supposed to have my leg
chopped off no I don't know about you
can I've done it without getting that
bit we went to Japan to play it for our
documentary so we were in Japan and that
was one of the first bits and atoms the
guy who edited Mason edited the
documentary we'll see next week and that
happened and he screamed at top of it
and everyone the room turned round it
was like yeah
seconds later everyone was doing it it
gets you every single time all my days
and you played through it twice right
yeah and it's it's a mixture like the
old Resident Evil this is your safe
point in the previous games it was
typewriter now it's a little more
updated not that much update yeah it's
gonna take that answering machine that's
plugged into nothing first of all that's
your parent but yeah this game is like
like the classic Resident Evil it's a
good mixture of jump-scares and like
really like intense tense moments
ancient intentionally like just leaving
stuff out instead of trying to scale you
just letting you get to that point and
yours
yeah your brain do it your nerves are
frayed I need everything for you so I
can combine items what so chem fluid so
you just - yeah they so you were in the
combine menu say fresh triangle yeah in
the combine menu it will basically show
you everything that you can currently
create and where you can do it but you
can also do it in items menu by
selecting like a item to be selected and
then it's like a plus sign next to it
which allow you to kind of combine in
the classical way right okay oh so I can
glue my leg back on therefore if the
worst should happen
that's nothing dude there definitely was
something in there I heard something
rattling around when you turned it Oh
see when you turned it around that's
smoked there's a lot of like small
design like audio design stuff that's
really cool
don't help it back here the foundry it's
good I'm eating people right maybe on
the fridges said like Zoey
well that's very for someone's they
sought a sick up watch there's another
resin you will stay oh the trunk
its back shadow check my house
you press triangle uh he actually pulls
out his wristwatch yeah if you hold it
l1 hold l1 yeah it's just out of maybe
you can get a little bit look at it if
you move and says let's yeah I see a
slightly yellow that's probably quicker
yeah then let's you defend against and
you still take damage but you're
reducing the amount damage that's
another thing that I really like so if
you go back in there and here yeah just
not into the room that you came out okay
it's just a small thing that I really
like press X on the door to close it
that's close and then slowly walk
through it this is essentially the
equivalent of the classic door anime
animation from Roseanne evil see how
they did it in when we used to cut to
black so you can do that in this game
you can use it too for example if you're
pushing through and you stop you can
have a little peek to see if anyone's
out there where I'm like I'm pickin this
lock down here no where am I going
what did you get from inside the room a
lot okay look you need me to do
something else oh yeah is tape so look
around there's this dude still floating
about though maybe where is that old
lady go Jack hey hey you gotta help I
mean is this your property just help me
me no no is he gonna get it from the
back you understand
I gotta get out of here this guy's not
listening understanding they're crazy
people in this house trying to [ __ ]
kill me all right you don't exactly seem
like you playing with yourself all right
you know this is the worst cop ever he's
gonna get murdered may not be involved
all right I'll tell you whatever you
want
why wait you gotta give me your gun look
officer
right deputy I want to see my name in
the obituaries but you want to be a hero
and save my life do you want to be a
hero
oh my god is he actually gonna give it
you a [ __ ] pocketknife I was gonna
say surely he's not gonna give you a
scar do with a knife cut that thank you
the fact that you're feeling that
attention and you're getting upset yeah
that the guy was not you can pin that
box with your knife oh yeah again upset
that the cop wasn't you know you wanted
out of there quick
yeah knows that you wouldn't be feeling
that in Resident Evil 5 or 6 to tell you
that much
I just want the conversation to be over
cuz I was fully expecting some guys to
come up behind him and kill him see it
plays an expectation it expects you to
do that me what about you know it's my
job don't you do your job and tell me
answer my questions you know I can't
believe me if I told you what the hell
how sharp is this shovel
these make moves man pitch time-wise
just kidding it don't mess the car up
watch him me wait in this car
the key though damn it's so much aid
it's not the aiming as bad as like
they're deliberately made it cumbersome
yeah Oh God it's the equivalent of
almost kind of very wonderful you could
either aim all the way to the floor so
now I need to get a car but the key were
you aim for
so he's tight them around so give me
space
[Music]
I don't know that was it wanted me to
interact the power going to seek one
don't smell got away
Oh hahaha okay where is it now I'll keep
running you over son it once with gout
how bad is he good
Oh God
oh god he's ripping the car around
he was really sick doughnuts
trustus Gary stove
Oh God let's finish this you and I no
thank you
oh yeah oh gosh my watch is rad Raj Ghat
I suppose your move is still moving
sorry how thin here okano ammo oh my
days I can I don't know it was a set
piece of what's not now it's pretty good
I fully just thought I'd failed my highs
being so fast falling it
did you see that oh stop it boy you're
about to see some more
[Music]
prior to but it left does it stay this
intense on the entire game yeah
let see how he put me on his bath Oh
after all that he's taking the time to
disassemble a photograph okay come down
from the upside and they rely on you to
tell me so why we've got to the point
where we're stopping actually goes small
brief just a small one
[Music]
I know Silla okay seems to be out for
the count you did take a non-event
bullet to the head the big dog
oh the ox door yeah oh okay
pie has proven its relentless dissection
than that and that surprises those
people screaming this dora feels very
old-school resin yeah this reminds me of
like the first mansion yeah so this is
like almost like a hub point oh really
yeah I mean it's an area you spend a lot
of time getting to know hydrogen kidding
me see that's through it I love that you
gives you that moment you think yes I've
got a shotgun and then you tell me like
no I can't use a shotgun so now you're
gonna spend ages thinking about that
shotgun
oh you can only have it under certain
conditions so yeah this you get to know
this is this is like the that kind of
like you come back to this area over and
over again and there's various puzzle
puzzle pieces if I done this correct is
it know you discovered a puzzle a type
of puzzle there all right that's one of
the types of puzzles I have in this game
you'll eventually acquire an item which
you can use to solve this puzzle I saw
that I saw the whole house like it looks
like coin size I never got that so good
not that dumb yeah o clock pendulum
interesting see these are these are like
remember how in resident I don't know if
you play there is an evil but it'll be
like oh you can't go through this door
the the padlock has the emblem of a
lizard on it okay
I know in that in those games would be
like really weird of it you'd be like
was it that's a father that's your
father oh my god no one explains it okay
smash that through yeah so in those old
games would be luckier the key has a no
the lock has an emblem of thing and this
this is the equivalent so if you look at
that door but it's a little more like in
keeping with the theme they've liked her
ass they've like nailed scorpions to the
door seeing what a fine key to get
through there so this isn't this is like
if you go upstairs that's kind of that
one too but okay so this isn't like
another part of the what would have
happened if I should save the bullet in
Shaa try it's right Ronny man
okay I got a bullets you can tango if
you look away name the game doesn't let
you shoot her shoot grandma she's an
innocent no one's innocent this say yes
and it's got like him a lot of
environmental storytelling stuff so some
more pieces I've downstairs he saw some
newspapers which would give you all that
step Margarito the lady
foreshadowing something that might
happen and later oh really she's around
that's the Duster thing in this game
these people are always around yeah you
never quite sure where they are though
but they're always that it always this
is ever-present threat and that's in
keeping with like resident evil 3 where
the Nemesis was always around it could
never predict where you would be on your
first playthrough so you got a pendulum
do you remember that other there's
another clock somewhere around it okay
yeah
I found more shotgun shells and I still
had denied the shotgun which I feel very
robbed for well you know there's
something that's all don't I need you
okay alright let's get more bullets oh
you son
he's like naked as well
can you hear his foot fence but oh my
god what are we go
oh no you find a safe space for safe
space right here let's comfy comfy it's
coming for you what do you mean it's
just Nikki you know thank you you can
take an old man by letting in the
shotgun room look alright yeah it's a
big house
you could run anyway apparently not
scattered circles I don't know it's
behind you you wrecked my baby come here
now's not the time for it you should go
around the way you came what dad says
that door you entered through smoking
from you I can't believe one jet let me
tell you shotgun this door
you should be safe now turn right oh
maybe not don't like what I do trying -
Jack yeah sounds like doesn't mean years
bloody hell
it's the music as well this is
everything he was gone
I start looking for me where do I need
to go pendulum in the clock in this part
of the house
you know what they say once family
always family is once again Clara you
should boy I knew that's gonna make
noise I bloody knew it my dog's head
what do I do the white dog's head is
that for the painting remember those
against the main entrance near the phone
when we looked there there were three
okay give me thanks this is for a dog
head you just need to go back man
not that way why not us along with is it
to the wall oh what's that noise you
should be pleased yeah that way
oh I thought you I thought you booked
for this boy he's on this side though
laughter I'm gonna poke the window so
moving at the end don't do that so you
can come sugar Joe somebody's running
[Music]
can I actually got the sugar now you
just flooded me again you can get it run
down again can I pause it with it boys
no there's no pausing in this game grab
it from the left
no never
can't keep a good man down I just need
time to
it's craft Oh ladies done already sad
enough of this
why do I do this talk head put down
stairs the way you came
we're in the bottom women in the
downstairs where the phone was all right
so obviously both [ __ ] we call her don't
mean anything
oh hey that's like my stuff says it was
me way downstairs Serie A ten you still
know God is there any point where you
can't hear these [ __ ] supposedly no
there's always that always the wrong
spot all right tell me what's for this
dog had was that you opened it he's
downstairs downstairs with nested see
you down there Gavin I've got six times
of that
[Music]
there you go find two more are you gonna
do this thing um nah I think you should
learn kill you because this let's show
the people way looks at Oh done you
killed him yeah it's not that it is that
forever
it's nice fancy talk Ed's they are very
far into this game
they're quite deep into this game we're
not very far that's your that's your
next one
there's also bubbleheads which gets
shoot it's very game you follow this oh
yeah he said he's there he's everywhere
I think that opponents good mister
everywhere I think my heart can't take
anymore and that's a that's a nice
little slice of Resident Evil's heaven
that's pretty much how it stays
throughout it remains in that sense yeah
fruit three quarters of the game are
mostly bad intentions a bit waste
thoughts ease off
well it doesn't ease off actually it
becomes a little more like heightened
for a while
great well I'm never gonna play this
young again basically here but if you're
looking if you're excited for it well
the minute we've got your awesome
documentary I'm the American team were
probably gonna livestream a good few
hours of this way more than I will so if
you want to see what happens after this
point because baby Dave can't get you
further go watch that yeah but for now
thanks so much for watching hope you
enjoyed make sure you like the video and
subscribe to GameSpot I need a cup of
tea I'll see you next time
welcome to family boy oh it was horrible